[Música]
bueno
vamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
les pedí que quitaran esto por favor
nadie ha marcado una diferencia siendo
igual a los demás esto lo dijo [ __ ] y
barnum en the wailers sound man esta
película que tiene a hugh jackman
cantando y bailando por todas partes
siendo feliz a pesar de la dificultad de
las situaciones en la cual intenta crear
un espectáculo con personas raras y
diferentes y en la que al final se sale
con la suya y crea el primer circo de la
historia ya la vieron
debía haberles preguntado eso al
principio de antes de contarles toda la
historia pero bueno espero que hayan
visto porque básicamente de eso se trata
eso no es lo importante sino que me
gusta esta serie esta serie esta frase
la cual se ve muy pequeña en la pantalla
porque me recuerda lo importante que es
fiel a mí mismo que está bien ser quique
siendo quique y las personas que me
conocen y mis amigos saben que utilizo
esta frase como una manera de aceptar
mis ventajas y mis desventajas
sigue siendo quique un ejemplo sería en
jardín de niños en primavera las
maestras habían dibujado özil veteado
unas flores en las jardineras y nos
habían puesto en parejas no teníamos que
pintar estas flores en las jardineras en
los maceteros
mi compañero al cual le vamos a poner
ausencia
ausencio porque claramente era ausente
de talento
les voy a explicar por qué
ausencio empieza a pintar la flor y que
siendo que se empieza a pintar la flor y
él solamente pudo trazar cinco líneas en
los cinco pétalos así que aquí que
siendo aquí que me limité a decirle
ausencio no te preocupes yo me encargo
así que ausencio se limitó a existir y a
respirar
mientras que yo me dediqué a pintar la
flor que originalmente tenía cinco
pétalos y terminó con cuatro no porque
me faltará tiempo para pintar el otro ni
porque lo dejara en blanco sino porque
me salí de la raya y terminé con un
pétalo desde este tamaño
y los otros tres de este tamaño y que
siendo quique perfeccionista desde niño
me generó un gran conflicto que hasta la
fecha es una experiencia que no puedo
olvidar como pueden darse cuenta no
perfeccionista
creativo
ese es quique siendo quique de niño [ __ ]
siendo quique de adulto es llegar a casa
de mis amigos abrir el refri agarrar
comida como si fuera mi casa
es quique llegando tarde a todas partes
sigo trabajando en eso o derramando el
café
en la mesa
y es que regresando la frase me gusta
porque nos recuerda
lo importante que es ser tú con tus
ventajas y desventajas y es que estamos
rodeados en una sociedad que nos inculca
que tenemos que hacer las cosas de una
manera ya predeterminada
estamos rodeados de tradiciones
estereotipos y mitos de etiquetas de
clichés de moldes en el que nos enseñan
que tenemos que seguir caminos que otros
han tratado se ha trazado anteriormente
para nosotros el encajar ya casi es como
un requisito en nuestra actualidad desde
que nacemos incluso se programa a
nuestro sistema de creencias
de esta manera niños azul
niñas rosa
los niños no lloran
las niñas tienen que llorar para
conseguir lo que quieren
no sé
en mi caso fue
los hombres no bailan
crecí en un sistema machista que ya no
únicamente afecta a mujeres sino también
a hombres
en el que ser diferente y no en el
aspecto en el que ustedes están pensando
sino en lo que te gusta hacer el precio
a pagar es ser blanco de críticas porque
porque nuestro entorno eso se le
programa a nuestro sistema de creencias
imagínate que tienes una computadora
nueva
para que funcione necesitas insertar los
programas e información para que te dé
resultados diferentes tienes que cambiar
esa información
lo mismo pasa con nuestro sistema de
creencias
y aunque pudiéramos creer que esto no es
tan importante realmente lo es
nuestra mente es como nuestro disco duro
nuestro sistema de creencias es la
información que depositamos en él
manera en la que nos vemos a nosotros
mismos la manera en la que vemos a los
demás e incluso la manera en la que
vemos el mundo y de manera consciente o
inconsciente nos lleva a tomar
decisiones y todo en base a nuestras
experiencias personales es nuestro
sistema de creencias personal el cual es
el cual a veces creemos que es el
sistema de creencias universal
hace nueve años después de trabajar
varios años de godín
me di cuenta que mi trabajo no me
gustaba
así que me inventé uno que si me gustará
renuncie
y entre críticas y palabras o frases
como nuevamente los hombres no bailan o
ya cosas ya más grandes como te vas a
morir de hambre
me armé de valor y decidí iniciar mi
proyecto de vida abrí mi escuela de
danza
lo cual parecía una muy mala idea siendo
hombre
sin embargo dije si lo voy a hacer lo
voy a hacer bien
y ojalá pudiera contarles la típica
historia de que desde niño sabía que
quería hacer y que en las posadas me
ponía a bailar en medio de la sala
mientras todos me aplaudían o que veía
vídeos de michael jackson y quería ser
como él
sin embargo no es así mi primer talento
fue el dibujo
pasaba horas dedicándole tiempo a la
creación de mis historietas de mis
cómics tenía cuadernos enteros con
superhéroes con historietas de
dinosaurios
etcétera etcétera
pero igual que con la danza en su debido
tiempo se me dijo
bailar perdón dibujar
no te va a dar de comer
así que
supongamos que me dijeron esto no me
dijeron que no
tú no puedes ser creativo necesitas ser
realista
así que en secundaria llevé el término
realista al taller de dibujo lo cual no
se parecía en nada a mis cómics pero
hacer trazos y maquetas no estaba tan
mal después de todo en bachillerato
llevé el término realista
al taller de construcción tenía que
hacer planos fachadas y cosas de
topografía que realmente nunca entendí
hasta que por fin me volví lo
suficientemente realista tal cual me
pidieron
decidí que quería ser arquitecto
y no porque me gustara sino porque era
lo que más se parecía a lo que yo quería
ser de niño que era dibujar
me limité a encajar y a una etiqueta mi
camino de pronto se volvió más angosto y
se vació de posibilidades
de alguna manera la escuela eligió por
mí
la escuela me enseñó que mi creatividad
era más un hobby que un talento
sabemos que hoy en día es muy difícil
alcanzar la estabilidad económica en
cualquier otra profesión o en cualquiera
de las profesiones sin embargo para la
sociedad parece ser imprescindible el
ser doctor ser ingeniero matemático
maestro político
pero no artista siendo que el ser
artista requiere las mismas horas de
preparación y sacrificio que cualquier
otra preparación o cualquier otra
profesión existen talleres licenciaturas
y doctorados
incluso el mundo nos ha regalado
infinidad de personas que creyeron en sí
mismos y decidieron volverse unos
muertos de hambre los cuales ahora
llamamos artistas imagina tu vida
sin tu banda favorita
sin tu película preferida
sin ese libro que lees cada noche antes
de dormir
sin esa serie
que utilizas para tu maratón de netflix
en chivo
sin esa canción que te alegra el día o
que te recuerda a alguien especial
definitivamente sería aburrida no sería
la misma
sir ken robinson dijo la creatividad es
tan importante en la educación como la
alfabetización
así que por qué no dedicarle las mismas
horas de creatividad a la creatividad
que a las matemáticas
hoy en día y este es un sondeo que hice
con mis alumnos en mi escuela el horario
de clases ocupa matemáticas ocupa 5
horas mientras que arte ocupa únicamente
dos horas de arte a la semana la clase
de arte es como una limosna para los
niños es como para tenerlos entretenidos
incluso a veces es como un relleno o
como una actividad extraescolar
parece que no fuera aspiracional el ser
cantante músico pintor fotógrafo o
bailarín
pablo picasso dijo cada niño es un
artista el problema es seguir siéndolo
una vez que crecemos
este año con mi escuela tuve la
oportunidad de competir a nivel nacional
con nuestro equipo en la categoría
junior niños de entre 8 y 12 años de
edad después de una muy buena racha de
competencias ganadas nos encontrábamos
en nuestra meta final el nacional de hip
hop
para mí el simple hecho de pararme en
ese escenario
me aterraba
y ni siquiera iba a bailar
sin embargo los niños brinca van de un
lado a otro por todas partes emocionados
y decían cosas así como profe profe que
nos vas a dar cuando ganemos
en primero yo pensé
como puede estar tan seguro de que vas a
ganar
honestamente
únicamente lo pensé
y la emoción del momento era tanto su
energía era tan contagiable era tan pura
tan honesta que lo único que pude
decirles fue lo que ustedes quieran
lo cual resulta ser una muy mala idea
para niños de entre 8 y 12 años no se
pueden pedir videojuegos pertenencias
dinero
qué sé yo
pero ellos para mi sorpresa respondieron
pizza
[Música]
sigue siendo aquí qué
él
bueno yo lo único que pude pensar fue
además de talentosos son bastante
económicos los muchachos
si le preguntan esto a sus papás
definitivamente no les van a decir lo
mismo
al menos no al pagar la mensualidad de
la escuela ni de la academia por
supuesto al final
éramos campeones nacionales
[Aplausos]
es todo gracias
éramos campeones nacionales y nos
ganamos el derecho a representar a
méxico en el mundial de hip hop que es
algo así como las olimpiadas del baile
para que me entiendan
y bueno ellos además ganaron pizza
claramente
y lejos de la medalla del premio del
reconocimiento personalmente me dejó un
aprendizaje
entendí
que los niños
realmente creen en su talento
que no tienen miedo a equivocarse
que no conocen el miedo hasta que un
adulto se los presenta
que el sistema poco a poco les enseña
que el error existe y que hay que
avergonzarse de él
para lograr una verdadera transición en
nuestra sociedad
debemos dejar estereotipos clichés
etiquetas moldes
atrás
los niños necesitan ser impulsados
necesitan saber que los adultos creemos
en ellos
que su talento realmente vale la pena y
que hasta los sueños se pueden volver
realidad y no importa el tamaño de tu
alcance no importa siempre puedes
impactar la vida de alguien más
si tan solo estuviéramos conscientes de
nuestra de nuestras diferentes formas de
realización
de nuestra manera de influir de una
manera positiva
en las personas
les aseguro que existiríamos más
personas felices
a mi entender la vida no se trata de
encajar a mi entender la vida se trata
de desaprender para crecer se trata de
cambiar de resetear nuestro disco duro
y esto implica el hecho de abrir nuestra
mente a nuevas ideas y nuevas formas de
realización
y aceptar esa responsabilidad que
indirectamente se nos asignó de influir
de una manera positiva con los demás y
de predicar con el ejemplo ese es el
verdadero precio del éxito el tomar tu
responsabilidad
para inspirar a alguien
hace algunos meses atrás
la mamá de uno de mis alumnos llegó muy
preocupada a decirme que el niño quería
dejar de bailar
él tiene 12 años recién está entrando a
la secundaria si de por si la secundaria
es una pesadilla
para muchos de nosotros
decía qué
un grupo de niñas lo molestaba por mover
las manos de una forma amanerada
un grupo de niñas
ya no de niños como a mí niñas a eso
hemos llegado en nuestra actualidad y
les voy a enseñar la manera en la que el
movía las manos
me lo pegaron
ayer en el ensayo ruin esto aquí que
siendo quique
es que ayer en el ensayo mis
herramientas de trabajos corrieron
peligro pero bueno me voy a salir un
poco del círculo esta es la manera en la
que él se mueve y como dicen las niñas
que es una forma a manera
regresemos al círculo
efe
rompe las reglas perdón amigos esto se
llama locking
y es una técnica dancística que se
utiliza para calificar en competencias
nacionales e internacionales
créanme para algunos de nosotros la
danza es realmente una cosa seria con
números y toda la cosa sin embargo estas
niñas dentro de su ignorancia lo único
que pueden hacer es señalar y criticar
algo que no conocen
como mucha gente en el mundo
el peor enemigo del arte es una sociedad
ignorante una sociedad tan ruin que lo
único que hace
es derrumbar
mientras que el arte edifica
en estos tiempos en los que todo va tan
deprisa
en los que el tiempo se mide en horarios
de oficina
en el que es más fácil
ver un monitor que vernos a los ojos en
estos tiempos más que nunca necesitamos
de la belleza del arte
yo soy artista soy apasionado y los
sentimientos son mi herramienta de
trabajo
para mí el ser artista es como estar
loco e invitar a otros a conocer tu
propia realidad y esta es mi realidad
para mí la vida es como un escenario en
el que hay críticos y espectadores
imagina que la función de tu vida llega
al final
no hay presiones porque no hay
espectadores no hay aplausos
porque no hay público
te encuentras parado frente a ti mismo
qué harías
de aplaudir y as
a quien habría complacido después de
todo
estaría satisfecho del papel que ha
realizado
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]